nous avons maintenant lire la presse de
ce vendredi
revue de presse signée sandrine gomez
bonjour sandrine
faut commencer votre revue de presse les
îles tonga ou les secours commencent à
arriver nous sommes dans le pacifique
oui alors cette petite nation du
pacifique
elle a été coupée du monde pendant
plusieurs jours après une éruption
volcanique un tsunami dévastateur
c'était samedi dernier les dégâts sont
très importants et c'est la chine qui se
réjouit filou mais est bien d'être en
première ligne d'être arrivée la
première sur les lieux avec l'aide
d'urgence un article ici du global times
ce qui explique que la croix rouge
chinoise a fourni 100 mille dollars d'
aide humanitaire noms célèbres donc ici
l'amitié entre deux pays et pour cause à
nous explique le times ce matin la chine
est très heureuse d'aider les tonga la
petite nation insulaire est en effet un
pion dans le jeu de puissance qui se
joue dans le pacifique et pourrait être
encore pousser un peu plus un peu plus
dans ce giron de pékin alors que
l'affirmation un militaire chinoise elle
est de plus en plus forte en mer de
chine méridionale mais aussi on le sait
dans le détroit de taiwan et bien de
façon plus discrète le gouvernement
chinois et ses entreprises publiques se
sont engagés dans une campagne en vue de
renforcer leur influence auprès des
gouvernements du pacifique nous explique
ce journal une stratégie qui passe
notamment par des prêts au développement
et une expertise dans les domaines de la
construction ou encore de l'exploration
minière
paulette pons la la presse
internationale qui est aussi suspendu
sandrine à cette dernière réunion à
venir entre américains et russes à
genève alors que cette séquence
diplomatique autour de l'ukraine dure
depuis deux semaines elle n'a rien donné
pour l'instant envoyé alors cette
séquence diplomatique elle était censée
à filmer à faire baisser la tension
autour de l'ukraine et bien elle
débouche en réalité sur un constat à
lire dans la presse notamment dans el
país nous sommes déjà presque en guerre
titre le quotidien ici un grand conflit
est sur le point de commencer redoutent
la journaliste du quotidien qui fut
correspondant à moscou elle en veut pour
preuve ici l'intervention russe au
kazakhstan
récemment ou mais aussi le déploiement
de troupes russes cette semaine en
biélorussie et puis bien sûr sans
oublier et bien c'est tintin cette
invasion de la crimée qui date de 2014
l'espagne qui dans ce climat de tension
et bien propose d'envoyer des soldats en
bulgarie pour contribuer au plan de
dissuasion contre la russie
regardez donc cette cet article d'el
país une frégate qui doit notamment
partir la semaine prochaine nous dit le
quotidien espagnol pour prendre part
donc au déploiement de l'otan en mer
noire ces tensions avec l'ukraine elles
ont aussi accentué la peur d'une
invasion sur un autre front regarder à
bien cette image qui est en une du
figaro ce matin un char leclerc du
battle groupe franco-britannique qui est
déployée par l'otan face à la russie en
lettonie cette fois avec ce titre les
pays baltes dans les pays baltes l'otan
vous le voyez s'entraîne à la bière avec
face à la russie est ici dans dans les
pays baltes tout près de la russie à une
centaine de kilomètres et bien c'est
l'armée française qui est aux
avant-postes de cette dissuasion a allié
reportage à lire dans le figaro ici à à
d'asie en lettonie où l'on procède à des
exercices militaires en vue un nous
dit-on d'une guerre de haute intensité
entre force et légal aujourd'hui à new
deal quotidien et bien ces trois pays
baltes vivent dans l'angoissé permanente
d'une reprise en main brutale je sais tu
de l'ours russe dans la presse aussi
l'hommage sandrine à une chanteuse
brésilienne décidé à 91 ans elle
s'appelait elsa swatch oui c'était là la
diva brésilienne une artiste dont la
carrière aura duré plus de 60 ans on
compte 34 artistes avec des mélanges de
son bas de jazz de musique électro de
hip hop ou encore de faim que c'est un
répertoire très éclectique
c'est faux il est sympa on vous le voyez
qui revient ici sur le parcours de celle
qui fut considéré comme la chanteuse du
millénaire dans un sondage réalisé en 99
par la radio bbc à londres
pour ce quotidien brésilien est bien
elle est un symbole de résistance de
courage elle a marqué des générations
brésilien avec sa voix rauque elsa
soares je cite et est une survivante il
elle a survécu à la fin aux persécutions
pendant la dictature à la violence
domestique à la mort d'enfants aussi et
puis à l'oubli de l'industrie musicale
aujourd'hui elle est célébrée rappelle
fo est sympa l'eau comme l'une des plus
grandes voix de la musique brésilienne
et puis un dernier un journal le journal
portugais publico qui rend hommage ici à
une reine insoumise une icône du brésil
est une voie de la liberté ici on peut
notamment lire cette phrase tirée d'une
interview au journal
je suis né pauvre noire et femmes c'est
dur mais on y arrive à voilà pour un
pour ce témoignage cela est bien de cet
artiste un merci beaucoup c'est andres
gomez pour votre revue de presse à
retrouver sur le site france 24 points